le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
avec 48 mille interventions en 2015 le
service départemental d'incendié et de
secours de la réunion se positionne
comme un acteur majeur du secours sur
l'île parmi les sapeurs pompiers un
grand nombre de volontaires s'engagent
chaque année pour la protection des
personnes bruno et sous-officiers à la
caserne de saint pierre sabine et
caporal chef au codis à saint denis ils
partagent leur quotidien entre leur vie
de famille leur activité professionnelle
et leur regard de volontaires pour le
sdiss
8h du matin à la caserne de pompiers de
saint pierre bruneau prend son tour de
garde
première mission de la journée vérifiez
les camions et le matériel pour être
prêts à intervenir à tout moment bruno
est sapeur pompier volontaire depuis 15
ans à l'origine de son engagement un
drame personnel j'ai besoin de mon père
dans des conditions que je me suis
retrouvé face à une situation où lui
étant dans un état assez critique je
n'ai pu effectuer aucun geste de secours
la passion moment je me suis rapproché
du siège départemental afin de
candidater pour devenir après des tests
physiques et des épreuves écrites bruno
intègre les équipes de secouristes osys
de la réunion il ya un certain nombre
d'épreuves qui ont été mises pour
sélectionner les candidats sapeurs
pompiers volontaires ces épreuves
passées effectivement ils sont formés
pour participer aux missions de secours
comme les pompiers professionnels alors
ce qui fera la différence entre un
professionnel et involontaires notamment
sur des missions de risques dit courant
c'est son nombre d'activités au total le
nombre de gardes qui sera différent mais
dans les équipements dans l'émission ils
vont faire la même chose bruno continue
de travailler parallèlement dans le
service de sécurité d'un hôpital en
fonction et cet emploi du temps les
artistes et professionnels on va appeler
la personne qui s'occupe des volontaires
du centre de chaque centre
et ensuite lui faut ni de disponibilité
pour le mois suivant la fête trois à
quatre heures par mois
on sera amené le dira
tell dadt telle date tel date pour 24
ans en fonction des disponibilités qu'on
aura donné ensuite le matin on arrive à
ça car l'habituel comme seulement pour
moi j'ai fait et on est piqué ont
vérifié nos engins tout à fait comme un
professionnel bruno va donc passer sa
journée à la caserne est pas question
d'attendre sans rien faire lorsqu'ils ne
sont pas en intervention les pompiers se
maintiennent en forme et révisent leur
base via des simulations
mon collègue
les sens
11 heures l'exercice devient réalité
bruno et ses collègues sont appelés sur
leur première intervention de la matinée
à saint denis c'est sabine qui se
prépare à prendre son tour de garde
secrétaire médicale de formation elle
est sapeur pompier volontaire depuis
huit ans une passion transmise très
jeune par son père lui-même pompiers
mais aussi par sa mère fait avec ils
m'ont entraînée qui va aider à préparer
examen les venues avec moi tous les
jours c'est un terrain c'est une passion
de mon papa mais très soutenu par ma
maman entourée de ses proches sabine
porte avec fierté l'uniforme des
secouristes cette année elle était même
la seule femme pompiers de lille a
participé au défilé du 14 juillet à
paris c'est l'honneur fiat et on se
retrouve sur les
billets et
sabine a fait ses premiers pas à la
caserne de saint benoît mais depuis six
ans elle partage ses gardes entre le
terrain et le codis
le centre d'appel d'urgence enterrant
jour vous êtes monsieur il ya beaucoup
de gens en fait qui croivent quand il
appelle il atterrit directement en
caserne vous faites ce n'est pas le cas
ils vont venir d'abord dans le centre
d'appels et ensuite nous les opérateurs
notre hall et de dispatcher de l'appel
dans la caserne qui est proche de la de
l'intervention faite
si les sapeurs pompiers volontaires
perçoivent des indemnités horaires pour
leurs services passion abnégation et
esprit d'équipé reste le principal
moteur des candidats on est pompier
volontaire parce que on à la mairie font
ce métier là peu importe ce sont les
femmes ou hommes volontaires on reste
des ventes mais avec la passion du
métier si tu il ya des jeux fait ce
qu'ils essaient d'en tout cas de
présence
une manifestation aux autrees 10 5e et
inculquer les enfants aussi des valeurs
les volontaires dans la structure de la
sécurité civile française sont la pierre
angulaire de l'édifice sur 250 milles
sapeurs-pompiers en france vous avez 200
milles sapeurs pompiers volontaires
c'est très important d'avoir des sapeurs
pompiers volontaires dans nos rangs
c'est un lien social c'est le lien entre
la population la nation et les services
d'incendié secours à l'horizon 2020 nous
voulons doubler le nombre de pompiers
volontaires un pompier volontaire c'est
celui qui a une activité normale un
professeur un médecin mais qui s'engage
en tant que pompier volontaire il y en a
mille trois cents à la réunion qui
travaille aux côtés des professionnels
pour garantir la sécurité des citoyens
flou nous invitons aujourd'hui
des jeunes réunionnais à venir
s'inscrire à se porter volontaires parce
que je crois que derrière le volontariat
il y a l'engagement sur des valeurs
républicaines du défendeur
le statut de sapeur-pompier volontaire
s'adresse à toute personne âgée de plus
de 18 ans voulant mettre son temps libre
au service du public qu'elles soient en
activité ou non quel que soit son
activité les candidats sont soumis à des
tests et des formations les sapeurs
pompiers volontaires peuvent effectuer
jusqu'à 860 quatre heures par an selon
leur disponibilité et perçoivent des
indemnités horaires pour plus
d'informations vous pouvez vous
rapprocher du centre d' incendies le
plus proche de chez vous ou vous rendre
sur le site
www.stib.be est 4 point fr
m